it couldn't come at a worse time before
the brooklyn before the brooklyn center
shooting minneapolis as you know was
already on edge why because of the
derrick chauvin trial
one historically black church that
shiloh temple has become a place to
process
all of these emotions that people are
having these days is creating a safe
space for members of the community
to talk through what they are feeling
and they are feeling a lot
jamie yucas recently joined a group
meeting at the church
jamie good morning to you good morning
gail they are feeling a lot
we sat down with 11 people from all over
the twin cities metro area
some were members of the church others
weren't but as everyone shared their
thoughts on the trial
we saw a community listening to one
another and working through
its trauma together our trauma extends
long before this trial and our work is
going to continue long after
why is it so important to process the
feelings that are happening
because healing is revolutionary right a
part of our pain and our trauma in this
country is that we have to keep
reliving this right it's almost like
it's may 2020
all over again i can't breathe
[Applause]
it's just real heavy to me because
it could have been my dad it could have
been my brother
it could have been my sons i have four
sons it could have been this young man
it could have been this man our
environment is
survival we didn't um
terrify terrifying community because of
george floyd getting killed
they took the community because they was
frustrated and they ain't getting no
answers
we prepare for the wedding we prepare
for our birthdays
but we don't prepare for tragedies so
what we have to do is learn how to deal
with tragedies instead of reacting
and when you were talking i was just
thinking y'all could stop
traumatizing us you know like y'all
could stop murdering us
like that is a real choice as well and
then we wouldn't even have anything to
respond to
because we know it doesn't happen to the
white community the way that it happens
to the black community you know they try
to
portray the black man as being an angry
black man and that's not what i am i'm
just
uh sick and tired of being sick and
tired right what's the one
feeling that has been elicited in you as
you're watching the trial
uh anticipation okay pretty much
everybody gonna say anxiety
about the whole situation is despair
because i don't know the outcome
but i am hopeful that this time around
we will have him convicted
so your word is hopeful helpful my word
would be
humanity why is that your word it's
important to see people
as human and i do watch it every day
and i see human people sitting in that
courtroom
and i often say um to my mother
that i'm sure if we asked shavin
could he change something he would say
yes
i do i really do you have a lot of
empathy
i do and even though he's sitting in a
courtroom and there's someone in his
life
that has been lost he's still human
and whatever the outcome i pray every
day that i'll be okay with
it but i pray for him too that whatever
decision is made he can live with it
is it hard for you to watch every day
yes it is hard but i do it because i
have a son
and that could have been my baby and
only for the grace of god it wasn't him
what's your one word um
this may be surprising but unity
why although we may not agree you know
completely nationwide on the trial
and about derek chavis actions i believe
that we can agree that there
needs to be some change absolutely
and unite that way and unite in that way
that last woman nia is 20 and lives in
her childhood home near the border with
brooklyn center
where on sunday police shot and killed
dante wright
who was her same age nia told us she
realized that easily
could have been her and tony i have to
tell you as someone who has grown up
here in the twin cities
i keep hearing from people on the other
side who keep wanting to dehumanize
and vilify these victims and i'm hoping
that conversations like
this one open their minds i do as well
jamie yuka's in her hometown of
minneapolis jamie thank you very much